happy Thanksgiving grab some turkey grab
some stuffing and relax there's football
on television on Thursday on Sunday it
is gonna hit you right where you need it
right in the kisser because we are
heading into week 13 the playoff picture
starting to make sense your fantasy
lineups are starting to matter so much
but now is the time when Warren sharps
models are clicking my moustache
crustacean shirt wearing friend how are
you lovely I'm much better than what I
would last week which was real shitty so
healthy I'm feeling good I knew you were
sick because when you texted me you told
me what time you woke up and that's
really the sign of someone that sick is
I feel awful I woke up at insert time
and then did insert disgusting action
and it was a great text so thanks bro
yeah I woke up like three or four
different times so apologize for that um
I do have a thank you that I have to
give Warren sharp early and you're
welcome to any of the listeners out
there that listened to what we did
preseason preseason we put in five
season long prop bets for futures just a
little future bets and a lot of it was
based off of Warren's books his
information and then also the advice of
our good friend Bill Kraken burger and I
can already say in November before
Thanksgiving we have money in your
pocket that is because on Monday Night
Football the Baltimore Ravens secured
their ninth win of the season giving us
an over of eight wins that's right in a
few months we turned 160 dollars into
two hundred and eighty eight dollars
right here on the left coast show Lamar
Jackson to the Ravens we don't just pick
them no in the division we bet them so
Thank You Orrin I appreciate the early
Thanksgiving gift
yeah you're welcome Ravens were just
that team for me you know they were they
were there was a few you know 49ers or
another one but Ravens were that team
where I thought the public was wrong the
market was wrong everybody was
undervaluing Lamar and you know I I
could I could thump my chest even louder
but we'll leave it at that
you guys the 33% knows how dead-on right
I was about Lamar Jackson yeah you too
we both we both were very strong on our
love for Lamar and his incorporation
into this offense before the season
started I think the other thing too is
like I forgot you have a Niners winning
the division outright profit which is
that's a well that's beautiful just
beautiful to watch that game last night
to see Lamar Jackson as Engler just
called a ballerina out there that's how
fluid he is I'm watching this defense
now reaching levels that you know in
weeks two and three we had a lot of
concern about and now they're operating
at a high level but to see this team in
the same week that the athletic and I
Kapadia I believe is the writers name
and I have enjoyed him when he covered
the Eagles diving deep into the
analytics program that they have there
the way in which John Harbaugh
integrates that meaning BER talked about
it last week the same week that Jason
Garrett clearly doesn't care about win
probability at all and doesn't think
about analytics the same there was
something very validating about that
Ravens team smoking the wunderkind Sean
McVeigh's offense and making that team
look archaic and I'm curious as it as
somebody that you really understand
what's going on there with the Ravens
and their acceptance of this analytics
what are we seeing right now in
Baltimore well we're seeing a lot of
plus TV decision-making we're seeing
buy-in from John Harbaugh I was in
Baltimore this past offseason the the
Yale grad Daniel Stern I was working
with him met with him these these are
guys that clearly know what they're
doing they know what they're how much
they're impacting their ability to win
games
and that's the beauty of it was it's one
thing to understand what you need to do
it's another thing for a guy like John
Harbaugh to buy in wholeheartedly and
just go with what these guys are
advising you to do and obviously he has
the final say in what to do but the cool
thing about what you see John Harbaugh
doing is he's trusting these guys that
he surrounded himself with whereas some
coaches might have the foresight to
bring in people but they still don't
really know if they're all the way there
and they still want to try to make some
of the decisions themselves and and he's
really allowing those guys to run with
it and the cool other thing that I see
from Harbaugh is he's letting these
players I just kind of embody their
spirit and their own attitudes and just
take the team where it's going and John
is almost like at times and this is not
the case but he's at times like along
for the ride sure these guys drive the
ship and he's just feeding them more
energy and positivity and just
reinforcing everything that's going on
there it's a really cool atmosphere to
see it's funny you talk about letting
them have their own personality it
almost seems that John Harbaugh has a
little bit of Steve Kerr vibes where
when that Warriors team could really
coach itself we get a lot of clips of
him on the bench going you know Steph I
love you and then I think about John
Harbaugh sitting down there and with
Lamar just go and I love you and it's
funny because Lamar and Steph are just
unpredictable seemingly undersized we
don't know if they can figure it out
superstars Daniel Stern Warren I talked
to you sometimes and and what you're
able to think about process and create
blows me away what is your view of
Daniel Stern what what is what is he
capable of and what does he bring to
that organization well you know there's
a few guys there that are working with
him but he I saw him on TV last night
he's one of the guys that's up there
god bless you he's he's sitting next to
Greg Roman in the box and he's
interjecting things during the course of
the game so you know there's a lot of
things that go into what I do and how
I'm consulting which I'm helping them
and a lot of it a lot of it is game
planning and during the week preparation
self scouting opponent scouting getting
them ready to have the optimal strategy
to win this game whether it's you know
from a pace of play perspective all the
way to the actual plays that they're
going to be running and ways that
they're attacking the defense but then
there's the element of now we're in the
game what do we need to adjust mm should
we go for it or should we not and so
having somebody there who's crunching
the numbers real time who could provide
you with that assistance is invaluable
to me I mean it's it's another tool in
the you know craftsmen's you know what
he needs to bring to the table in order
for them to have the optimal chance at
winning a game Warren what I love too is
the one issue that I have with the Sean
McVeigh explosion and by the way if
anyone's selling stock in Sean McVeigh
I'll buy it they'll figure out a way to
get this salary thing done Jared Goff is
the issue the offensive line is the
issue
Sean McVeigh will figure it out because
that dude will self Scout but the thing
that kind of upset me a little bit about
last year was everybody kept trying to
recreate it but it was really because he
is so darn special that you meet him you
talked to him and you go oh wow he's on
a different level and we can't recreate
that I really believe that like we could
see a lot more non-traditional head
coaches hired because of this ravens
thing because they're gonna look at a
special teams coordinator and go oh wow
he's open to new things maybe other
people are down for that but also you
can do this you can embrace analytics
and win probability and selectively play
prediction you can embrace that and that
is replicable and that could go
throughout the the season which I think
would be really good up David asked me
this question last week it seems like
sometimes Warren you're always
professing throw on first throw on
second every time but you know he
mentioned you know there's gonna be bell
curves where you probably don't want to
throw every down so what is there a
perfect amount of throwing on early
and getting away from one of the most
frustrating things about understanding
analytics running on first running on
second and not having success know the
answer that I always have for when
anybody in the media or teams ask me
like what is the optimal pass rate in
the NFL what's the optimal first time
pass rate the answer at this point in
time is just one word more it's just the
word more now eventually we'll get to
the point where the defense is
sufficiently adjust to take away those
passes whereby it's more plus TV to call
run plays and you always want to keep
that defense guessing so if you become
overly predictable if you're a team
that's throwing the ball 95 percent at a
time on first down then that defense can
adjust the anticipating pass you know
the beauty of the first down play call
and sometimes even the second down play
call if you're on schedule is the
defense has no idea what's coming right
you might be running you might be
passing where's the situations that the
defense knows what you're going to do
are those long down and distances to go
third antics plus I'd if you decide that
you're not going to pass the ball then
guess what the defense is happy go ahead
run the free it doesn't really matter
right no I really think that most teams
still need to pass the ball more often
the lone exception is if you're a team
like the Ravens and you're having a 65
percent success rate on the ground when
you're running on 1st and 10 and you're
gaining five and a half or six yards per
carry then by all means keep it balanced
keep that defense completely guessing
run more than what the analytics would
tell you to do because you need to be
crunching these numbers based upon not
just the league average but your own
team your opponent so on a given game
there might be a higher or a lower run
rate because of weaknesses that defense
you always need to be optimizing your
game plan based on lock facing at the
same point so John is very clearly
paying attention to these numbers and
adjusting accordingly why do I get the
feeling that the other team that's
performing at the highest level right
now the San Francisco 49ers
Kyle Shanahan may
he isn't paying attention to it it's
just ingrained into his brain to call a
game like that is that the vibe that you
get - yes I believe that Kyle has like a
little bit of Bill Belichick quality to
him where he simply knows how to attack
a defense and a lot of the things that
he's choosing to do are second nature to
him and he doesn't really that we should
say he doesn't feel like he needs but he
just doesn't really need the backup
support from the analytics to advise him
what to do all right some of the numbers
that I study and the trends around the
league that I study have and we've
discussed with the 33% you need to pass
more on early downs you need to play
more heavy personnel and pass out of
those heavy sets you need to use a lot
of play action you need to be aggressive
early in games to try to build halftime
leads like all of these various
different they all do it naturally he
just does it naturally and let's not
forget I mean they were having success
coaching with a lot of different systems
in quarterbacks right
he was adapting to what he had to work
with in Atlanta before this stop he was
in like his family they were the ones in
Washington Houston
Cleveland right everywhere Atlanta he's
been around he's had to work with the
ingredients he's like one of those
really good chefs - okay this is what
you got me well this is what I'm gonna
make this meal based upon what you got
here I think this is going to taste
really good he does that and every
single stop that he goes to he just has
a better control of what his ingredients
are in this stop at San Francisco
because he's the head coach and so
involved in personnel so he's able to go
out there and say hey guess what John
Lynch I want a really good fullback
because I've always wanted to have this
great fullback here I didn't have that
in Atlanta I worked with what I had
there here I want a really good fullback
so they bring in Kyle use check you know
so they're going out and adding the
types of pieces that he wants in this
stop the thing is - is having worked
with Simms and then the snowing way too
much about Kyle
he also selects guys that are so
multiple where he loved the Pierre
garçon so who do they draft in the
second round debo Samuel he loves
running backs that are in wide reciever
bodies just like that kid they got at a
Baylor I don't remember his name this
year rookie that we were kind of hoping
they'd play him a little bit more but
use check could also be a wide receiver
George kid ole could be a running back
he could be anything and the fact that
he was able to get all of those wide
receivers as a former wide receiver
himself on the same page they're the
best taught most refined wide receiver
routes in the league and they did it for
two years with CJ Beathard and Nick
Mullens now that we have Jimmy Garoppolo
it can operate at that next level I said
on Monday this most storied rivalry that
could go into the Super Bowl with San
Francisco New England I said the one
that I was rooting for rooting for the
most was San Francisco and Baltimore I
talked to Warren briefly last night he
said those aren't even the best matchup
possible what is Warren sharps dream
Super Bowl matchup in Miami
this February well let me put it this
way there are some matchups that I would
prefer over this from an association
perspective although III think that
there's a lot of good options out there
on the table but I think a really fun
matchup if we want to talk about a
couple of quarterbacks who are severely
battling right now for MVP I want to see
Seattle going up against Baltimore mmm
because I don't look I'm like you I want
to see what happens when Kyle Shanahan
goes up against Lamar Jackson and these
two offenses going to task on Sunday
unfortunately this games at 1:00 o'clock
they should you I'm game
Sunday night Monday night what have you
but I don't really want to see the
rematch I would prefer not to see the
defensive adjustments that heats email
you like it when the Super Bowl is two
teams that did not face each other in
the regular season
then usually in the Superbowl it's a
lesser scoring game know that there have
been a Justin smade there have been
adjustments made exactly I want to see
how these teams can take the two weeks
and try to figure out what their game
Baltimore has played Seattle in the
regular season though Baltimore has
played Seattle but this was a situation
where Seattle did not have their full
complement of current wide receivers
right now it was rainy we know Russell
Wilson does not perform as well in the
rain Baltimore was in the road in a
hostile environment and so from that
perspective you're right they have met
once before but that's the matchup where
I want to see dry conditions I mean we
could get rain in Miami yeah Cheryl oh
but I want to see perfect [ __ ]
conditions for these two teams to go at
it and and let's watch Russ cook against
Lamar because we've got two
diametrically opposed philosophically
different coaching staffs here one in
Baltimore is aggressive go for it on
fourth down anything to win the game the
other is Pete Carroll and Seattle where
we're going to kick the field goal we're
gonna trust what we've always done we're
not going to be over-the-top aggressive
and like I want to see if Pete gets
forced to come out of a shell a little
bit what that offense would look like if
they end up you're letting Russ cook
more often and go for it on more fourth
down so that's really what I prefer to
see more so than you know watching these
two guys go back yeah the idea of every
possession that either Russ or Lamar is
touching the ball is very exciting the
notion that we'd have two weeks to break
it down and if it does come down to
those two with the MVP which is
announced the night before the Super
Bowl that would be incredible the fact
that it could be those two MVP
candidates the award goes on Saturday
and then they're fighting for the real
championship on Sunday
Russ wins the award Lamar goes I got the
trophy I really cared about or
vice-versa
I didn't even think about that but they
are the two in my opinion
just mahomes has been a little bit Limpy
I just think right now that that Russ
and Lamar are operating at a level above
everybody else and when you said that I
went yeah that probably would be awesome
that would be great
to all of the 33% that said hey record
with Warren early so we could talk about
the games thanks guys thanks for being
my producer I appreciate it I'm so happy
that you guys care but it's funny when I
mentioned to Warren how does
Thanksgiving impact the gambling world
you said oh it's already hit you said
that I couldn't believe it
I thought when I think of the Sharps I
think of people that are not going and
sitting with their family and going past
the cranberry I think they're people
that are going where's uncle Tommy oh
he's down there at the Sahara locking in
a few big bets for today but you said
even the big shark groups on
Thanksgiving week they're bettin Monday
and Tuesday I was blown away yeah so the
good thing about what I do and what the
other guys who are really sharp
syndicate guys do is we set our own
hours we work whenever we want to work
we fire when we want to fire and and for
me at least it involves very little
sleep but when you've got a lot of
family around and that type of thing you
do want to enjoy some of those events
and activities so it's not to say that
lines are not going to be moving on
Thanksgiving but when you got like
Thanksgiving when you got Christmas hell
there's been times where certain betting
groups right they'll tend to go on X Day
and all of a sudden they're firing the
board two days in advance and I get with
my guys and I'm saying well you know
they move a little bit early where they
do oh well you know one of the guys is
getting married on Saturday at the at
this uh resort in in the islands and so
they're getting some stuff down before
they head over there like so it is it is
a pure fact that we set our hours and we
go and we want to go and if I'm gonna be
eating my Thanksgiving meal with my
family
I might be betting my games before then
as opposed to an hour before the game so
absolutely you know holidays and other
events within families are going to
impact out in your right you might think
that these guys are just like slaves to
betting because the schedule here in the
after bet at a certain time but we bet
when we want a bet and and move when we
want to move usually on a Monday how
much do the lines move there's been some
movement like this year a little bit
more than usual but I'm not oh not on
Thanksgiving Monday on a normal Monday
do the lines usually stay a little bit I
would imagine they'd wait until the
injuries come out yeah there's a little
bit of movement but it's not nearly the
to the extent of what we've seen so
let's see I have a few teams here that
you you told me have already moved
Chargers Tampa Bay Green Bay Tennessee
in this Thanksgiving week we are
recording on Tuesday what are the lines
that you're already seeing some of the
sharp groups push oh well Tampa Bay's
first to form us me not line open 3.4
and off at some books that's down to a
pick on at most spots right now some
spots are still Jacksonville -1 but that
started off at Jacksonville favored by
three and a half four and it's already
down to pick'em yes Wow
so like how do you read that when you
see that you go either I miss the boat
or now let me see if I can find value in
Jacksonville no I think that's a problem
with a lot of the sharp guys that I work
with first of all ok let's just make one
thing perfectly clear when guys are
getting down on a Sunday night after the
line comes out because we're recording
us on a Tuesday obviously days early so
a lot of these lines are moving either
Sunday night into Monday morning the
limits are smaller right but it's
perfect for these mid-range groups who
only want to bet a couple of dimes on
these games so they're getting down to
thousand dollars here two thousand
dollars there and they're pretty small
and and they're you know it doesn't
really matter they could bet it in a few
spots a few thousand dollars and if they
get you know five figure exposure to a
game that's all they really care
right for most larger betting groups
they're betting as often as they can but
they're really trying to get down a lot
more than that they don't want to move
the number too much but if they see a
number that's going to be gone like that
was just wrong by the books they'll get
involved on it a little bit too so there
was I mean some of these games have
certainly moved by to three points at
times and I don't view it as oh my god I
missed the boat completely here there's
nothing I can do if I still like Tampa
Bay even at this number I'm not gonna
let the earlier guys deter me from
taking this but as you've seen this
season there there's certainly times I'm
releasing games on Monday to if there's
enough I want to get I'm going on Monday
I'm not gonna let the the day of the
week necessarily stop me from taking a
good number if I don't think it's gonna
be there on a Thursday when the limits
get raised gotcha
any other games that kind of jump out to
you that think excuse me should be
talked about in terms of early movement
from the shark groups that caught your
attention
well Cleveland definitely was another
one there was definite money on
Cleveland that's up to two at some spots
the Steelers named actually I see some
two and a half out there as well add
that started that was it actually opened
it three for the Steelers at some spots
and is down now down now to one and a
half to two in favor of the Cleveland
Browns yeah
the Steelers did make a quarterback
change they announced that they're not
starting Mason Rudolph they're starting
duck Hodges which I think is the
appropriate move to make but some people
obviously feel like he's probably not
ready or they just like Cleveland more
than what the odds maker did yeah that
jumped a lot and then I saw some
movement in Green Bay that one started
at seven a half for the Packers it's now
down to six and a half I'm seeing in a
few books and then Tennessee the
interesting the fighting Ryan Tannehill
started off as a three and a half point
dog for Indy and now I see it at two and
a half and a lot of spots so across the
number yeah you got you lost the hook
and then across the three so that was a
big it does
sound like a lot in that one just a
point and a half but to what sorry
actually just a point but it's actually
two pretty pretty big things if you
missed out on that a little few little
glossary terms for people a dime is a
thousand dollars a hook is when you get
three and a half so that if you win by a
field goal you still cover and then
losing the three means that the line
goes from your favor I three and a half
to your favor by two and a half so
you'll lose that nice even three which
is a very popular number which games end
and that was that was learning betting
terms before we get into EDS R which I'm
about to tell everybody [ __ ] raked
again I think the most important thing
is for us to self Scout I lost money and
on this Sunday I'm sure that you lost
some money on it this Sunday my
Instagram DMS were telling me that other
people lost money it's okay it happens
but the Denver Buffalo over didn't hit
and I know that a lot of people would
love to come up to you in the middle of
the street and go hey what the [ __ ]
Warren why didn't that hit so let's just
do it now and we'll talk to the 33%
because we are very honest people well
first of all a few things because I love
dude your notes on that we're incredible
incredible so let's back the truck up
for one second here crack has said this
a lot when people come up to a mass and
give me one winner give me this give me
that yeah we're betting a lot throughout
the course of the season and right now
I'm hitting I want to say close to 70%
on totals which ago which is completely
unsustainable right I mean historically
I'm at 60% over 13 years of giving these
games out publicly which is also
unsustainable so there's a lot of magic
going on here but I'm not gonna hit 70%
and if you asked me to pick one game
right there there's a you're gonna have
a coin flip a lot of different things
together this particular game did not go
nearly the way that I thought it would
in a couple of situations we needed a
couple of things to happen here number
one we needed the Buffalo Bills and
we're going to talk about them when we
talk about the game against the Cowboys
yep we did then to stick with their up
style of offense and guess what for the
first three quarters they did they
stayed at a pretty high tempo
offensively well we also needed it
typically takes two to tango when you're
talking about going over the total and
we did the Denver Broncos to have
success running the football and not
completely kill themselves when they
passed it and unfortunately what
happened is they did have success
running the football but their offense I
think for the three the first three
quarters averaged 1.8 yards per pass
attempt and in hindsight like the worst
element of this was when you're looking
at what the weapons are that the Denver
Broncos have to throw the football to
number one we know that the Buffalo
Bills are good against tight ends so no
offense one of the biggest weapons like
the number two most targeted guy on the
Denver Broncos he's going to be
minimized to some degree and then they
have a really good number-one cover
corner it's real obvious we trade a v's
who's going to take away
Portland Sutton to some extent and so
what happened was both those things came
true and then the Denver Broncos really
don't have much outside of that from a
threat to burn you in the past the thing
that was killer too is Brandon Allen's
pick in the red zone when that happened
I was like that's that's that's how you
lose it that's how you hit it under a
crazy thing about this game is it seems
like it came nowhere close right nowhere
close at all and it really didn't but
guess what when you have a total at 37
okay let's pretend he doesn't throw that
pick and they score a touchdown we're
sitting at 30 on the game has Atlanta
we're sitting at 30 all you need is
another a defensive touchdown something
at some point during this game and
you're at worst pushing so like the
margin for error of going under a game
like this is so super small but normally
what you're expecting and you're hoping
for in games like this and I wrote about
in the handicap is you're expecting a
really short field at some point
hopefully a few of those you're hoping
for maybe a defensive score and we got
nothing we got no help from any of that
so yeah I'm I certainly don't
I will never
you know I don't think the 33% will
fault me for this I never apologize for
a game that doesn't hit and I never
spend this length of time like we're
doing right here patting myself on the
back no you do not over the point is
we're just discussing this but when
you're giving out you know and doing as
well as we are on totals it's just it's
just another game it happened to lose I
certainly don't advise people to be
betting like $1000 on this game and
$20.00 on a few other games and if one
game is gonna lose your weekend and
caused you so much dress you should not
be betting you're either betting too
much and you need to figure out how to
manage your bankroll or you probably
shouldn't be betting in the first place
because losses are gonna happen and
certainly there's going to be many more
to come on the rest of this season's
podcast as well you know the future I
just think it's it's the reason that I
brought it up is I find there's a lot of
shows that never address it and for me
it's important to address what did we
not see what didn't happen and it
because you it's better to be thorough
because then you're not selling snake
oil but what I say is when people say
what the [ __ ] I go yeah bro it sucked
for me too I lost and then I say I say
[ __ ] and then the name of the
quarterback that lost so I go off [ __ ]
Brandon Allen I think oh yeah [ __ ]
Brandon Allen oh my god that was easy
yeah because the true thing is is that
you know it's every week you're kind of
looking and betting the NFL is crazy but
the fact that you're 71% rely on totals
is wild almost as wild as the success of
EDS are since we started charting this
back and I think week six or seven so we
introduced weighted EDS our last week
and when you combined how you did in
traditional and and waited
you went six and one straight up the 80s
our model did other reason at six and
one and not of eight is because
Tennessee / Jacksonville was in both
models and I could I'll tell you what my
little left go both EDS are model theory
is going to be tested this week because
I'm any team that shows up in both
I'm going yes because I love one data
point against the spread it went six and
one as well
the only thing interesting there is that
the Cowboys did cover against the
Patriots while there was a loss in terms
of the other spreads the other thing is
- in the weighted EDS are two underdogs
popped up last week both covered readers
won outright Cowboys was able to cover
that spread in the incredible decision
but excuse me the Jets won outright
Cowboys were able to cover the spread
because of the incredible Jason Garrett
field goal down seven plus six I mean
Warren I prayed for that my whole life I
can't believe we saw it I can't believe
it oh yeah no there's no doubt when
you're petting these games and you are
you are hoping that a coach makes a
boneheaded decision late that's gonna
help your bet but hurt his football team
usually that rarely rarely happens and
this you you certainly got that and it's
amazing to me the quotes in the comments
that Jason Garrett came out with putting
stuff on tape afterwards about well we
don't really study in game analytics
during the game and I'm thinking when
else would you study them after the game
to find out what you did wrong I mean
that's the point of studying in-game
analytics is to look at them during the
game you know look at what your
probability is based upon a decision and
figure out is this in my best interest
to try to go for this or not that's the
whole point of them it's not to look at
them after the fact so I don't know what
he's talking about there I'm surprised
he put that on tape and then Jerry Jones
comes out and says well we like these
numb we like statistics but we've got so
many other factors at play with weather
and things of that nature that we really
just have to go with their gut feel and
I don't disagree with what Jason Garrett
did in that situation and I'm sure you
discuss this with the 33% already but in
case you haven't I'll summarize one
minor point here that's actually pretty
important
forget the decision on fourth and seven
the key is if you know
with the mindset that we're going to go
for if we can't convert then you're
going to call plays differently on
second and seven and third and seven so
that you can have a really good shot on
fourth and short to go for it because
you know that you need this touchdown in
order to have a chance at winning this
game the goal is not just to cover the
spread the goal is to win the game if
you're Jason Garrett and from that
perspective and mindset he's not talking
to his play caller his play caller is
not communicating this to the
quarterback like all of them are on
different pages so that's why I'd AK
Prescott's taking endzone shots here on
second and seven third and seven
thinking like well I'll just be kicking
the field goal this is my only chance to
win the game led Jason Garrick came out
and said if it's fourth and short one
two or three I'm going for it well why
aren't you telling Kellen Moore that so
he can set up fourth and short at worst
and why aren't you telling Dec hey man
go ahead and run the ball on this third
down if there's a lane because if you
don't get it on if you don't get the
first down we'll just go for it on
fourth down like none of that's being
communicated at all it's it's just a
disaster yeah taking moonshots to Blake
char when in the back of the endzone
it's not a strategy it's a save me but
you're right if dak turns it up and
makes it a fourth and three now we have
a philosophy and that's how you beat a
team like the Patriots but you know as
they say Warren good teams win great
teams cover and in my mind Jason Garrett
is a great coach because that man covers
so thanks pal
you are twenty five and six over all
right now adsr is nineteen twelve and
one against the spread and as I
mentioned both underdogs covered so you
did say before it is a blend of
traditional and weighted you are leaning
a little bit more towards weighted I
know you are a little bit but we still
want to get the traditionals so let's
start with traditional this is factoring
in the entire season and schedules and
all that stuff
your number one mismatch in EDS are is
the Eagles over the Dolphins and that
makes sense with the size of that spread
yeah it's it's obviously clearly being
accounted for in the spread certainly
everybody's looking away from the Eagles
with all the problems that they've had
and you know you're an Eagles fan you
got a hope that there
some type of good luck in the water here
that you could get some of these
receivers back I mean I know Carson
Wentz makes some boneheaded plays and
puts the ball in the carpet or throws an
interception when he shouldn't have you
know and sometimes that's very
frustrating I'm sure to the Eagles fans
it's also very difficult and and Dan
Orlovsky put out a video showing us like
when your receivers are not running the
right routes when they're not sitting
down in the right spots you've got guys
that aren't experienced out there
because your top three receivers aren't
even playing in the football game you're
your without DeSean Jackson who's been
out a massive disappointment
I was super thrilled when they got him
in the eyes and I was tweeting up a
storm about it he's been gone all year
except for what week one and and I think
that's it
then you're without al Shawn Jeffery
you're without Nelson Aguilar and some
of these guys like you're hoping might
be able to go so you're still game
planning a little bit that they could be
there and then all of a sudden their
scratches and so you have to work with
what you've got
it's it's a tough situation when you're
without your wide receivers and you're
calling up guys from the practice squad
who are playing a significant amount of
time that game yeah at the same point
I'm watching teams like the Steelers of
the Niners get their wide receivers up
to speed in two weeks and I'm watching
the Eagles have a second-round pick that
barely knows how to run a slant and
we're in week 12 so eventually you look
at the wide receiver coach and you go
what are you doing because you're not
devout there's this notion that people
forget that this isn't Madden alright
you're not an 82 and then you play well
you become an 83
no like coaches matter like they teach
you things they said you don't only get
taught in high school that's why there
are some coaches that sky rock in the
profession and there's some that kind of
float around you don't want to hire them
yeah I'm kind of worried about that okay
I need to stop getting angry number two
in terms of traditional EDS are matchups
in NFC West battle the Rams over the
Cardinals what are you seeing here in
this matchup with a Rams team that a lot
of people are hurling question mark said
and and I am to this this number
obviously when we were coming up with
this did not account for what the Rams
did in last night's game but it
just update really quick this game is in
Arizona it started at Rams favored by
four and a half it is now down in many
spots at three yeah and so that's why I
like from the traditional method that's
looking at full season long so I think
what we need to clarify traditional is
just like the season long EDS are we're
gonna go through the trending which is
just the last four weeks right so this
is the team that will not show up in the
trending model this is looking at some
of the games waiting them more heavily
where they were beaten up on some more
inferior teams it's interesting here
you've got the Cardinals coming off of a
bye and you know the certainly the early
money is coming in on the Arizona
Cardinals here and you could kind of see
why taking them plus three at home where
they do have a good home field advantage
would be appealing especially with Shaun
McVeigh coming off of a short week where
are you right now with Shaun McVeigh
where where do you stand I already kind
of spoke about I didn't ask you
yeah look I knew what they needed to do
to beat the Patriots in the Super Bowl
and you're still you can't get over it I
know you can't I I can't I can't get
over the lack of foresight to make some
of those moves to trust in the season's
worth of information that we have to
make those modifications to your offense
to stop running so much 11 personnel
when you don't have cup out there like
some of the he's a group he's a there's
too many accolades to say how good he is
at what he does
I completely respect everything but
there are certain things that need to be
accounted for differently factored in
differently into his process moving
forward if he wants to try to have this
sustained level of success and guess
what a lot of those things become more
important when your roster doesn't have
quite as much talent spread everywhere
when you're paying a quarterback and
you're paying a running back such as
they are you can't fill up the 53 which
is with as many good players so guess
what becomes more important the
analytics guys who are suggest
seeing different things so yeah I I the
coolest thing about that game last night
to me was Sean McVeigh was taken over
the world
last season running non-stop 11
personnel for the last couple of years
making the Superbowl everybody's talking
about him they go higher all of his
friends and anybody who worked for him
before to become head coaches or
coordinators because of you know his
experience with Sean and face offense
meanwhile in the midst of all of that
John Harbaugh takes his offense gets
ready Joe Flacco midseason
implements a run heavy style with not 11
personnel which is three wide receivers
we're not gonna go speedy up tempo with
all these little wide receivers we're
going to go heavy we're gonna get lots
of tight ends in here we're gonna run
the football a lot with a run based
quarterback doing everything that the
rest of the NFL didn't want to do it's
just funny to me the juxtaposition of
those two things happening in the same
year all the praise going to Sean
McVeigh John Harbaugh out here doing
something completely different that most
people around the league
who's studying the trends are looking at
him like what's this guy doing you know
why is this guy here what I like the
most is that Vegas took a bath on that
game big time like how big how big would
do they need the Rams to win that game
well all of the public was smashing
Baltimore like they knew the final score
and so all of the sharp guys all the
Syndicates I mean you know I I work with
a lot of these guys I see what different
games this guy that guy this group that
group all these different everybody's
lining up on the Rams plus three every
single body is lining up on the Rams
plus three and there was absolutely no
way that I was contemplating going like
there wasn't even a chance that I was
looking at doing that now I didn't lay
the three three and a half with the
Ravens but there's absolutely no way
that I could have gotten on the Rams in
that spot so I don't know what the
win-loss was in terms of what the sports
book did I just know that the public
certainly cleaned up and the sharp guys
definitely lost but again
what people need to understand - the
sharp guys in the groups it's just one
freaking game it's not like they're
loading up their whole bankroll on this
one game just because the public on the
other side they're betting thousands of
games over the course of all the ports
in a year so it's one loss to them they
move on they hate losing I hate losing
you ain't losing everybody doesn't want
to lose you want to win everything you
place but they definitely lost that game
for sure so the number one season-long
EDS are mitch matt mismatch was Eagles
over dolphins number two is Rams over
Cardinals numbers three and four also
show up in trending so I'm gonna kind of
say that now we'll get to but number
three is Chiefs over Raiders and at last
check here I see Kansas City is favored
by nine and a half we always would like
smaller numbers but that's okay number
four season-long EDS our mismatch is the
Tampa Bay Buccaneers over the
Jacksonville Jaguars that one started at
Jacksonville favored by three and a half
I look now and I see it at one some
places have a pick'em Bovada actually
has Tampa Bay favored by one which is
very interesting but I would I want to
kind of compare now to the trending EDS
are number one for the last four weeks
EDS are mitts match is also the Eagles
over the Dolphins which is interesting
it's the number one in traditional and
in trending does that give you at all
more confidence or do you see a number
like nine and a half and a team with as
many question marks as the Eagles and
you go not worth it well I'm I'm
personally not gonna lay the points here
with the Eagles but I find it very
interesting considering that the
trending only is looking at games were
Ryan Fitzpatrick was the quarterback and
it's also looking at games where the
Philadelphia Eagles have played terribly
where everybody's criticizing what
they're doing you know but keep this in
mind look at the defense's that the
Philadelphia Eagles have had to go up
against over the last several weeks
you're talking about the Seattle
Seahawks and doing the Patriots the the
Chicago Bears are in there too
Buffalo Bills Buffalo Bills all these
like good defenses that they're going up
against now they get to go up against
the Miami Dolphins so it's certainly
going to be a massive drop in
defensive efficiency that they're going
to face there so that's probably what
the the trending is picking up I'm gonna
take a left go flier here big Dallas got
hurt game for me you smash the Dolphins
with heavy sets Dallas is the guy yeah I
think Dallas needs to get more attention
there he definitely is a big factor he's
a he's a big x-factor let's put it that
way he's a big x-factor for this team
from a mattre perspective and I think he
needs to become more of an in-game
factor for them as well because he's
he's very talented as you know I think
so number two trending EDS are not in
the traditional EDS are is Chargers over
Broncos and as you mentioned before
there has already been a lot of line
movement this game started at the
Chargers favored by one and apparently
the sharp books already knew what our
trending ETS are is because now I'm
seeing that's up to two and a half even
three I see it at the win right now so
some early money's come on the Chargers
but they are the number two mismatched
and EDS are over the Broncos this week
yeah off the buy off of the bad loss to
the Kansas City Chiefs it's it's a tough
defense that they're going up against
Denver's got a very good defense but you
know Denver's offense is bad and I think
we also have the return of Derwin James
here so it should be it should be a
fascinating game but it's a short
favorite right now that you would have
to lay if you like to go betting on the
EDS our model it's interesting it's also
Denver coming off of a disappointing
loss on the East Coast coming back for
25 alright so okay the third one for
trending EDS are we are putting an
asterisk next to and that's why we're
doing five because a third one is jets
over bengals but the asterisk is that
Andy Dalton is back
so the trending model has been focusing
on Ryan Finley but now here comes Andy
Dalton which you know what I know a lot
of people are gonna kill the Bengals
they looked at Ryan Finley they got
three games of sample size and they said
you know what he's not the guy let's put
back at Andy Dalton let's try and win
some games
I would wonder if AJ green comes back
too but I also think that this is an
interesting indicator on how well the
Jets have probably been doing in the
recent EDS are models as well yeah and
look this is exactly what we predicted
on your show this summer before the
season even started that the New York
Jets are going to face a brutal schedule
to start here and a very easy schedule
to close the year especially on with
regard to opposing defenses so if you if
you look at the strength of schedule
metrics they face just that they faced a
brutally difficult schedule to start the
year and now they're getting a lot of
these defenses that they're able to have
much much more success against and I'm
happy for Sam Darnell because you can't
imagine I mean you you know it right but
like for people who are just like not in
New York and don't study the NFL like we
do the the amount of it roll and and
hatred towards Sam Kendal kosha
commonhelp was just egregiously
horrendous in my opinion everybody say
in this guy's a terrible quarterback you
can't do anything
meanwhile he's playing all these top
five pass defenses he's got injuries
he's got a mediocre offensive line to
get that offensive line and now we're
seeing how good he looks on some of
these throws in his ball placement and
and and kind of his pocket mobility in
his awareness and so I'm just happy ford
arnold like people think that i root
against certain teams or i I hate these
these teams or players I want everybody
to to optimize their play :
I hate it it hurts when you see a guy
who is better than what he is but he's
in bad situations so he's not performing
up to that level and then all the media
and everybody else comes in just
steamrolling hatred towards him so it's
just because most people that discuss
the NFL are reactionary and they blame
everything on the quarterback and it's
absolute nonsense but that's why we take
advantage that's why I picked up Sam
dartle in fantasy three weeks ago and
it's been great and I've been playing
them over Aaron Rodgers because you're
supposed to look ahead guys and we did
forecast this this is a lot what
happened to the Giants last year
why they had second half optimism their
first seven games were insane we told
you they'd start off one in six they
bounced back and this is how coaches
keep jobs to like Adam GaSe went from
like fire and three weeks ago to being
like this team if they went out could
make the playoffs of what great
development and Craig Williams has
really turned than toerner it's it's
just very funny to me also I don't know
if you saw the story that after the game
saying darn 'old went out and made out
with a girl and got drunk inside
slightly humble brag if I wasn't wearing
sweat pants I was going to be there I'm
happy I wasn't because I the whole time
I would have been like don't look at
them let them do whatever they want I
just
New York is funny everybody thinks they
could be anonymous but as soon as it's
like drinking on a Sunday everyone's got
their camera phones out and texts and
TMZ and crap well yeah I was very happy
I wasn't there I showed her the
headlines she goes weren't you gonna go
and I was like yeah I would never do
that ever
yeah I I just me personally like I see
both sides he needs to be able to do
what he wants to do and get kicked back
in half a beer at the same time like the
public display of affection with random
girl that you're meeting their problem
is I know exactly where they were and
the private room has holes that the main
room can see through so you kind of
think that you're a private but when
you're drunk you think you're private
and you're really you're just in front
of everybody
whoa is that classic song during my day
we think we're alone now
oh right yours a back goodbye day okay
number just pop Jets one more yeah if
you look at their schedule okay they
have played what is it top 13 past
defenses they've played six of them to
start the season top 13 past defenses
they went oh and six in those games
oh and six in in those games against top
13 past divas talking about Patriots
twice bills Eagles Jaguars and Browns
oh and six against anybody else after
the top 13 okay
they beat the Cowboys they beat the
dolphin
they beat the Giants they beat the
Redskins so therefore no against teams
outside the top 13 their own six against
these obviously uberta how many top 13
teams are left on their schedule right
now Lauren let's send the Jets to the
playoffs unfortunately they only have
three more they played the first four
now they've got the Raiders the Bengals
and the Dolphins in consecutive weeks
immediately after that though to close
out the season
you've got the Baltimore Ravens
Pittsburgh Steelers and Buffalo Bills
all three of those are top ten past
defenses okay well hey man I'm excited
for these next three weeks as Sam darn
'old it also makes my preseason
prediction of the Jets getting a
wild-card berth a little bit more
respectable I'm just gonna ride this
Ravens thing until the Sun because it's
my favorite prediction ever the fourth
team in the last four weeks that's been
trending on EDS are the biggest mismatch
was the number three on the season long
which is the Chiefs over the Raiders
this is currently a nine and a half
point game for the Chiefs Trey Wingo put
out the tweets but these are statistics
that I have been keeping track of but
I'm gonna give all the credit here to
Trey apparently in temperatures under 40
at kickoff Derek Carr is Owen for
averages a hundred and fifty two passing
yards per game with a fifty-one percent
completion percentage with a touchdown
to interception ratio of three to four
and a QB our total of nine a QB our
total of nine it's supposed to be in the
30s at Arrowhead now perhaps the Trey
Wingo man I'm sure this all came from
ESPN Stats & info but props to Trey
Derek Carr on the road away anywhere
else 14 and 25 at Arrowhead oh and 5
everywhere else is passing yards per
game 285 at Arrowhead 186 the completion
percentage drops by 8 percent the
touchdown interception ratio goes from
50 to 24 to 3 to 5 and his QB R is a 15
Derek Carr is at Arrowhead and the
Chiefs are face
after a bye week by nine and a half any
other information there on traditional
and trending I know it's nine and a half
but should I go to the window Warren
well let me just tell you this the other
what do we know about and you read we
know he's really good with extra time to
prepare true super good okay now I just
looked back looked up right now
what he's done against the Raiders since
he's came to Kansas City in 2014 and
he's nine and two and seven and four
against the spread both of those losses
the two losses were games on Thursdays
hmm
I remember one Derek Carr drove down and
they had six opportunities inside the
five because of all those defensive pass
interference does remember that and
Amari Cooper ran over two hundred yards
yes that was week seven in the 2017 see
where they ten points in the fourth
quarter and they upset the Chiefs by one
point so if you remove those games he's
the the short week games and give him
like a regular rest week he's undefeated
against the Raiders and of torn average
margin of victory there yeah sorry
because I'm gonna be honest if it's
around eight or nine I'm gonna bet this
game I don't care if it's nine and a
half there's too many good things okay
so the average margin of victory is in
the non Thursday games is fifteen point
two oh my god and last year they won
well they won by seven in one game but
the Raiders scored 17 in the fourth
quarter to make that game a little bit
closer and they won thirty five to three
it'll final game earlier this season I
was a game they won twenty eight to ten
and nobody scored a single point in this
third or fourth quarter so that was the
game that they played earlier this year
where the Chiefs were on the road in
Oakland and and smoked in by 18 points
man I know that it statistically been
proven that when teams play back-to-back
road games they perform a lot better in
their second game and of course there's
the bounce-back for the Raiders after
being embarrassed by the Jets but that's
all
lotta trends there Warren that's that's
that's like six or seven data points
that I would just go off one of them
yeah I mean I will tell you this this
line you would have to use like a six
and a half point teaser to bring it down
to three because it's nine and a half at
some spots but they certainly would work
for a teaser like I would prefer getting
it through the three because then it
becomes much more valuable if you got a
nine and a half
go ahead spend the extra a few cents to
use the seven point teaser bring this
all the way down to two and a half that
would be a good leg one of a teaser I'm
leery of playing the double digits in
the NFL but that you're right they're
certainly a lot of favor of them you've
got ETS are in favor of them and last
but not least you've got the market
which is moving in that direction as
well which I'm also seeing that the the
line has dropped from 41 and a half to
fit excuse me fifty four and a half to
fifty one and I have to think that's
Derek Carr related because this seems
like a game where one team will be doing
most of the scoring if these trends of
course play out yet and that money on
the under is very real that is a very
respected betting group not me but a
different group that took the under and
is has hammered it all the way down to
51 51 and a half you think there's any
value in the 51 little little little
chiefs under parlay action while there's
51 and a half if you want to go with
them I would have to look at my model to
see if I think that there's any
remaining value there but I could let
you know later
yeah we'll do that off here okay and the
fifth last four weeks EDS are is also
one that was forth for the traditional
EDS R which is Tampa Bay over
Jacksonville and underdog alert we have
underdog alert I was the worst alert
ever Tampa Bay favored but they are
underdogs by one and they're popping up
in both models and I usually hate bettin
on Tampa
especially after Jameis Winston throws
two picks in the first quarter but still
throws for 400 yards and Mike Evans and
Chris Godwin keep doing it but if
there's one team that's been getting
their doors just blown off
it is this Jacksonville team and I am
NOT gonna put this all in the feet of
Nick Foles because really the defense
has been getting destroyed they lost 42
to 22 the Ryan Tannehill and the Titans
30 33 to 13 to Jacoby Brissette coming
back and Marlon Mac just going off and
then the game before that the game
before the bye they lost 26 to 3 to the
Texans and that was the last game for
Gardner Minshew
so this team in the last three weeks has
lost by a combined 140 excuse me 90 yeah
a hundred and one 236 so I I just it's
still Jameis but where do you want to go
on this one
well a stat that I tweeted out that I
found pretty fascinating here on first
down through the first three quarters
the Titans against the jaguars
Tennessee's offense averaged 27 yards
per pass attempt and an 80% success rate
when they threw the ball when they ran
the ball nine point nine yards per carry
and a 61 percent success rate so was it
well like go on King like if you're
running the ball for 10 yards of carry
on first down like running 95% of the
time right like do your thing because
you're stomping these guys and that
that's actually one of the reasons I was
talking to crack about this game because
this was a total that I did give out to
clients we took the over and in doing
already no no this is this is I'll talk
about last week's game yeah it tightens
against the Jaguars took the over there
and he I think he was going to get his
nail his uh massage or something and
when he went in beforehand the the it
would look terrible like the halftime
score was like 7 to 3 or something like
that something really low and he
couldn't believe when he came back that
the game is like sailed over the total
and Tennessee scored 42 on their own we
took over 41 and I said one of the big
factors in this game first of all there
was some bad luck touchdown call off the
boar and other things in the first half
but one of the reasons why I liked the
over was because Tennessee's been a very
explosive offense with Ryan Tannehill
and
Jacksonville has the worst defense in
the NFL against explosive passes and
rushes over the last month and seller
playing Chris Galvin and Mike Evans now
they're playing Chris Connor went in
Mike Evans but the point was that even
when Tennessee which I liked I stuck him
on all my contest cards Tennessee minus
three was the number yeah Alta mately
that game got that too like five I think
by off but when Tennessee has the lead
they're going to just keep building on
it because you hand the ball up to your
running back and boom he's getting ten
yard yeah so it's not the situation
where you're up by 17 in the fourth
quarter and you're just running you
can't do anything I mean they're gonna
continue to keep scoring so that's
definitely a factor here when you're
talking about the Bucks if they're gonna
be able to run the ball and pass the
ball the key to be Tampa obviously you
can't turn the ball over you have to
move the ball through the air and have
some success because they do have a
pretty good run offense so that's gonna
be minimizing Leonard fournette the
other concern that I had about the
Jaguars now we're talking bout tennis
Tampa Bay and Jacksonville is I don't
remember this but the first game for
Nick Foles when he came out and played
after his injury they ended up like
running that Leonard fournette at like
six carries they ran the ball nine times
total it was awesome old show and Doug
Marrone came back after that game that's
why you have to do your reading and said
we're gonna pound it with Leonard it was
my mistake it's all on me called too
many passes we're gonna incorporate
Leonard more into this game now Leonard
did have an OK game against the Titans
but you know they certainly were
ultimately needed to be more efficient
in all aspects offensively here though
this is not the team the Tampa Bay
Buccaneers that you want to be pounding
your running back yes last week was the
Vita veía coming-out party it was like
the first time where everybody went holy
crap maybe when he suffered that injury
in training camp in his rookie year
it gave us a bad idea of what he could
be since he was the number one inside
defensive lineman taken in that draft
and pairing them with in Dhamma can sue
I mean we've been talking about it since
week three or four when they played the
Saints because we didn't think that
Teddy Bridgewater could actually throw
over the top
but last week was the Vita via
coming-out party and if the Jaguars
tryin pounded against them they could be
in for a very long day yeah I think it
would be a stupid game plan I don't know
how but it is the Jaguars so I wouldn't
put it past amore
that's what I'm saying I don't know how
much they're focusing in on like our
most optimal way to win this game I will
tell you their offensive coordinator
John heaps eleuthero loves to throw the
football so he would be happy throwing
the football it's just a matter of does
Doug Marrone influence him too much John
Dee Filippo I'm not gonna try and do a
metaphor needs to stop working for head
coaches that are afraid to throw the
ball like he worked for Zimmer and he
worked for Marone like two guys that
grind it out let's run the ball and
what's interesting is you know Marone
was the offensive line coach for Sean
Payton you'd think he kind of learned
something from that but at his core he's
offensive line coach and we see with the
bilk aliens in the world they like to
run the ball
so it's interesting hundred percent I
definitely think that John Dee fluke
both has strengths and weaknesses but he
was there under Frank Reich he was there
working with Doug Peterson he knows the
style that helped the Eagles win the
Super Bowl
even with a backup quarterback getting
inserted as a starter they were still
going to be a balanced team but leaned
towards the past a little bit yes so
we'll see what strategy they come out
with here but it definitely is a game
where you have to there's one way to
attack the Tampa Bay Buccaneers that is
correct
and we'll find out soon if they know
what that is
I feel like I'm gonna watch the first
tribe and then live bet if I see like
three runs I'm just gonna pound the
Bucks well the hard part is like they
might they might try to run early no
Belichick like Bill Belichick will do
that too he would run the ball early on
a decent run defense on the first series
maybe didn't the illusion to see what
they're gonna do to see if we're gonna
have any success but then BOOM
very quick in-game adjustment he's not
he does not hesitate at all
this is going to be a Tom Brady 45 pass
attempt game here I got a tip for you I
got a tip for you yeah Doug Marrone
no Bill Belichick you might be onto
something
all right let's talk about our favorite
games from the week Thanksgiving
I really have Bill's cowboy circled it
is the best game is there is there
anything though that jumped out to you
about Chicago Detroit or New Orleans
Atlanta that you're like you know what
this is good information from the 33% I
know I didn't talk to you ahead of it
but because it's the first game and I'm
gonna be home with my family and
probably wanted to put money is there
anything on Chicago Detroit or New
Orleans Atlanta um
not nothing from me at this moment you
know I'm gonna I've actually what I do
it's Tuesday right so it's for the 33%
so they figure out like kind of my
normal operating schedule is I'm first
attacking the most optimal spots that I
see the most edge the most value so I've
circled some of those already
I'm digging into the support trying to
do as much reading as I can waiting to
get some injury information where I need
it and then I'm gonna look to fire on
the games I see the most advantage from
where I think the law oddsmaker is wrong
those two games did not really stand out
to me from a totals perspective as being
egregious so I've moved on to other
things but there is this Dallas Buffalo
game is certainly a really interesting
one to this guy Buffalo at Dallas 4:30
Thanksgiving Dallas started off as
eight-point favorites it is down to as
low as six and a half I'm seeing a lot
of sevens across the board the total and
this one has pretty much stayed the same
at 45 this is a buffalo team coming off
of another win in which they pull it out
but they don't really beat up a Broncos
team at home and Dallas coming off of a
game in which their head coach before
the game might they're rumors hey he
might go to the Giants after the game
the the owner is saying we got
outcoached what stands out to you for
both sides here for this 4:30
Thanksgiving game well first of all the
thing that we kind of already discussed
before the pace of play was still
extremely high for the Buffalo Bills
yeah dive into that so I would expect
that that pace of play
we'll stay consistent for Buffalo in
this game especially when they are
probably trailing at some point right
there are six and a half to seven point
underdog through the first three
quarters of that game they oppelo Denver
Buffalo Denver Buffalo operated at 25
seconds per snap which is extremely high
the prior week they were at twenty four
point eight you know most of the league
is down at 29 seconds per snap and it
doesn't sound like Oh was you talking
about you know and Philip Rivers is at
about 41 right so the other were like
four seconds but but that that makes a
big difference because some of those
plays you're actually going much faster
and then you'll have place where you are
substituting guys in where you do decide
to slow it down to get the optimal play
and you're slapping it snapping it with
three to four seconds left on the play
clock so they are getting to the line
quickly day ball is still sitting up in
the press box and this is where like you
know credit to this show that's actually
talking about this because I don't hear
anybody else out there talking about the
change that the bills paid remember how
much praise the Atlanta Falcons got for
modifying their defensive coaches and
doing all this stuff and I was here and
a lot of different people talked about
it
heading into the game last week I
haven't heard anybody talk about the
fact that they moved brian de bal up to
the press box day ball is up in that
press box he sees the field better
they're getting to line of scrimmage
quicker twenty four point eight seconds
per snap in week 11 24 seconds per snap
sorry 25 seconds per snap in week 12
they're going to Dallas and this is the
other big thing about this game that's
going to be a big factor in my opinion
and this is the other element nobody's
talking about is the usage of 11
personnel what is very important when
we're staying at the line and calling in
place quickly we want to make that
defense tired we don't have time to
substitute guys in so this was Sean
McVeigh spends a lot of his day in 11
personnel is because just stick your
three wives out there one tight end one
running back you can call a lot of
different plays out of those groupings
and we won't ever have to worry about oh
we're in third and long so we need to
switch things up because
we can just keep those same guys out
there so it's basically like we can use
a first down second down third down no
matter the situation this grouping
should work
we never after pull Buffalo wasn't
running 11 like that all year buffalo
was like 65% 11 personnel below the NFL
average the last two games through
quarters one two three because fourth
quarter they got leads they're been
heavier person on there it is
unbelievable
nobody's talking about this out of the
last two games they've gone 97 percent
11 personnel in the first three quarters
of the games have brined a ball and the
Buffalo Bills 97 percent we've only
called three plays three plays where
they were not in 11 personnel through
the first three quarters astonishing how
much they have adopted this new
offensive philosophy now last week one
of the reasons that kind of like Denver
I thought Denver might have a shot here
is because guess what Denver was really
good at defending yeah what personnel
well guess what Dallas struggles
mightily to defend weapon personnel
Dallas is very bad it oven personnel on
the season they're allowing a fifty-two
percent success rate to 11 personnel
through the first three quarters of the
games they're allowing I think eight
yards per pass attempt almost 5 yards
per rush attempt against 11 personnel
they're much better defending heavier
packages so when i factor in what you
told me last week about Buffalo and how
they haven't faced a lot of really good
running teams and now they're going on
the road to Dallas to face a team that
really at its core still wants to pally
with the rock and really against the
Patriots probably should have kept going
this sounds like an interesting little
total venture that maybe we can partner
in I think there might be some
partnership opportunities on the horizon
on look there's not a okay so we'll
probably do something on this game but
let me just pull back the curtain a
little bit to the 33% yes I appreciate
that
there's a couple of different reasons
you want to go on various different bets
in general
some of it could be your power ratings
your math models things about you
finding numerical advantage there's just
the edge other games there could be
certain elements that the oddsmakers
probably aren't factoring in and in this
particular case I really don't think
because I searched all right I wanted to
figure out before that game started on
Sunday morning I searched the internet I
searched Twitter to find out is anybody
talking about Brian D ball in the press
box and all I saw was a couple of
stories that like one Buffalo newspaper
wrote like two weeks ago
well the week right after it happened on
like a Monday or a Tuesday
nobody had talked about it in recent
days except for Buffalo Bills mafia you
know some of those like you guys that
are root for the team and they're like
keep the ball up in the press box with
his gray mustache because it's working
you know stuff like regular food it says
mustache not anybody from the national
media so the media has missed this i but
oddsmakers haven't picked up on it yet
and if they're going at a much faster
pace and they're gonna be calling a lot
of 11 that Dallas struggles to defend
and if Dallas is gonna be able to run
the ball last week Dallas I'm sorry the
Denver Broncos actually had success
running the football I'm pulling up the
numbers right now because fortunate I do
now I'm at the tip of my tongue but
Denver Broncos I mean they're like I
said their quarterback Brunell was
terrible Denver had five yards per carry
and a fifty nine percent success rate
on the road in Buffalo and guess what
else that I hated about this total but
not enough to get off of it the wind it
was like 80 mile-per-hour wind no Rose
dome b5 and it wasn't enough for me to
get off but I definitely didn't like it
think about what Buffalo's dealing with
there from a defensive perspective a
team in the Denver Broncos who have no
offense they only want to run the
football you don't have to worry about
defending the past that much because
brain and Allen we're gonna stack the
box try to shut this run game down it's
windy we don't care if brain Allen tries
to throw the ball down the field he's
not gonna have success
and guess what Denver still average 5
yards per carry
still average of 59 percent success rate
now I think with doubt with Buffalo
coming to Dallas having to defend the
air and the ground no weather conditions
I think DAX gonna have a very balanced
game here as long as the old line holds
up and gives them a little bit of time
they should have success doing a lot of
different things against this Bills
defense game of the weekend is Sunday
1:00 o'clock diners Ravens we're not
gonna dive as too deep we're got a
little heavy right now but it is Niners
at Ravens starting off Ravens man a line
opened at 4 and a half for the Ravens
and it is all the way up to 6 after that
ingmar also asked me a question during
the week about you know the Niners
defending mobile quarterbacks just after
three weeks of Kyler and rust kind of
have a success against that vaunted
defense and now it's Lamar but six is a
big number for a Super Bowl contender
like the Niners to be an underdog but
with the Ravens at home you know they
look unstoppable yeah it's it's hard you
know this is another game where I could
tell you probably the sharp guys who
have been fading San Francisco for weeks
in a row are probably going to get on
the Jimmy G bandwagon in this game and
let the public bet what they saw
most recently which is not Jimmy G
totally annihilate Aaron Rodgers and the
Green Bay Packers that was Sunday Monday
we saw a you know coronation of Lamar
Jackson on Monday night so the public
certainly coming in on the Baltimore
Ravens here I think one interesting
thing in this game we'll see how San
Francisco is able to deal with it but on
the year the Baltimore Ravens who only
ranked 25th in rushing efficiency
defense that's on the year now I'll have
to look at the four most recent trending
defensive performances because I don't
have that updated through last night's
game but I haven't fifth worst run
defense over the last four weeks prior
to this game against the last night so
that accounts for Marcus Peters and the
secondary getting better
obviously but that run defense is still
problematic and if San Francisco can run
the ball here that's definitely going to
help out you know they had success
running they've only played three run
defenses that ranked bottom nine I think
actually bottom ten
let's do bottom ten they beat the
Cleveland Brown sorry they beat the
Cincinnati Bengals 41 to 17 they crushed
the Green Bay Packers last night or two
nights ago and they obviously took care
of business throttled the Carolina
Panthers 51 to 13 the Baltimore Ravens
are in that category with their run
defense so it's kind of be interesting
well Kyle Shanahan has planned here to
try to attack them on the other side you
know Baltimore their offenses humming
they're trying to get out build leads so
that you can't run the ball so that
you're forced to pass into the teeth of
that defense in the second half of games
gonna be fascinating to see how
Baltimore is able to deal with this
ferocious pass rush and they lose
Metzker oh they're starting Center last
night we'll see how big that ends up
being exactly one of the interesting
things that I noted though about that
game why I thought another reason not to
take the LA Rams here Erin Donald great
against Iran stud applies pressure
really good but when you're not throwing
the football all that much as Baltimore
does his pass rush is muted to some
extent and if you're calling a lot of
run plays to the edges
you're not running right at him anyways
so you know that's the thing that you
wonder about here is when you're taking
on the 49ers whose strength is their
pass rush and causing havoc when you can
putting them to the inside and negate
them with an outside running game that
as well as what happens when you only
throw the ball 17 times right
if Baltimore's I trap them back and
passing the ball as much as some of
these other teams that pass rush is not
gonna hurt Baltimore as much as it Ward
another opponent I'm just gonna tell you
the total for that game being 46 was the
shocker
for me I know that these two defenses
have been great but it's been proven
analytically and out there in the
football field that great offenses will
be
great defenses over and over again and
this is Kyle Shanahan and it's this
Ravens offense and I just thought there
was gonna be a five in front of that
number I did not think it would be 46
yeah I think the trick is just how good
that each of these teams has looked and
if you look at the scores that they've
put up it's it's basically if this game
has a shot at going over it's because of
what those offenses are doing I mean
they're you just said 51 to 346 like
it's not like they're beating teams 25
to 8 I hear you look I'm not I'm not
gonna fight you on this one I'm not
gonna fight you on this one ok that's
another good sign for me I'm just gonna
sit here and smile my friend is there
any no should know about the Niners
defense having issues with mobile
quarterbacks well we saw him play three
straight games against quarterbacks that
can move around they played the care
about or twice in Russell Wilson ice and
Russell Wilson in a three week span and
they allowed what 25 plus points in each
of those games so if a quarterback is
not at his spot where you think he's
going to be when you're playing this
wide nine defensive technique where
you're rushing the edge and trying to
bend around and go after this guy who's
sitting there and all of a sudden he's
out there you are exposed and what's the
other thing that this wide nine defense
struggles to deal with it's the running
game because of those lanes we've talked
about this previously which is one of
the reasons why they struggled against
the Arizona Cardinals because Arizona's
a good rushing offense you take those
wide splits a lot as that the offensive
front does and this is why your San
Francisco 49ers ranked number 2 against
the past but number 19 against the run
and guess what else a little secret
little nugget here the 49ers defense as
great as they are one of the worst teams
in the NFL on third downs mmm I know
those numbers are going to change
because of what happened with Aaron
Rodgers but heading into that game one
of the worst teams in the NFL on third
downs guess what Baltimore does they
don't give a crap about third
because if they don't get it on third
down they're going on fourth down
but Baltimore's offense is one of the
best offenses on third downs to begin
yeah my only my only concern now is
there is almost guaranteed rain looking
for Sunday at one o'clock so we'll see
rain if it's not pouring down rain is
okay if it's if it's pouring down rain
I'm gonna look at some of the forecast
while you tee up the next thing but we
want to look at wind and we want to see
how heavy that rain might be Sunday
Night Football Patriots at Texans
Patriots you know just coasting towards
another by handling teams that they need
to at Houston started off favored by
four and a half it's already down to
three it is Bill O'Brien against Bill
Belichick it is to Shaun Watson who has
had some success in the past against New
England at the same point
New England owns Houston when it comes
to vital games like the playoffs how
does this sit with you I want to see
what New England's offense looks like
out of the cold in a dome without
weather to deal with right it's been two
weeks of Eagles cowboys and mush yeah
and and so I just want to see what this
offense really is this is a little bit
of a litmus test for me there's no JJ
Watt to have to deal with
we saw what Baltimore just did against
this Houston Texans defense I don't know
I don't know what you know New England
obviously has his struggles I personally
have felt that New England's defense is
not as good as what they were i sat here
on this show on it so could the Shaun
Watson have a little bit of success is
getting eight games gonna come down to
you can they protect the Shaun Watson or
not if they can't protect him I thought
they would have a better shot of
protecting him against the Baltimore
Ravens
they didn't can they protect him at home
against his Patriots defense if they can
I think this is the first game that
you're gonna have the availability of
all their wide receivers when they've
gone up against the New England Patriots
and Bill Belichick
because there's been a number of games
where what's his name full fuller has
been out so you get fuller you get
Hopkins you got stills you got Aikens
and fells who are really emerging as
reliable weapons at the tight end
position and then they're running backs
I've ever performed this year yeah so I
think this games absolutely fascinating
early money has certainly been betting
when you say a game is fascinating those
are the games I don't bet on because it
means it's gonna be fun to watch but
it's really hard to figure it out yeah
this is one of those games where I'll
just tell you point-blank the model
hasn't shown anything strong so I'm
looking at what are the edges in terms
of mismatches or matchups so I'm noting
that we got fuller for the first time
I'm noting that the past rush of the
Houston Texans their offensive line has
been poor in the past but can they be a
little bit better against Bill Belichick
in this spot what will the Patriots
offense look like after dealing with
these poor weather conditions and you
know situations that are out of their
control they're just trying to go out
win games they don't really care what
the margin is at this point they're more
than happy to win ugly and and I think
to some extent they were able to shut
down that Dallas Cowboys offense last
week on account of the weather
conditions which played perfectly for
them right
New England hasn't played any good
offenses for most of the season they've
had to want the easiest defensive
schedules in the league by comes to
Shaun Watson at home and here comes the
Shaun Watson at home and you're not
gonna have whether that's gonna hamper
the passing offense is here so I want to
see give him a little bit of protection
I want to see what the Shaun can do
against this secondary total is a 44 and
a half right now and I'll just say that
this is a good week for Tom to look good
15th ranked pass defense the Houston
Texans with I mean Whitney Merciless was
hobbled last game and they really
haven't had a pass rush DJ reader has
been phenomenal but internal pass
rushers I feel like a lot of times
Belichick can get ahold of especially
when there's only one the this to me
feels like a very nice James White Rex
Burkhead under
let them romp and then on the other side
it's let's watch the Patriots and Devin
McCourty and Patrick Chung deal with
will fuller and really see when we get
on a fast track and you you're you are
afraid of us beating you deep what can
happen because we'll fuller is a kind of
guy that can strike fear into anybody
like I put him up there with the meet
Cole Harmons and the Tyreke he'll not at
that level but right below those guys
and the statistics back that up the game
results back that up when he's out there
DeSean is phenomenal anyone will foot
when will fuller plays to Shaun Watson
is the best fantasy football player in
the league yeah on a points per game
basis I would not doubt that at all
the other interesting thing here is the
Houston Texans struggle to defend
running backs out of the backfield they
were in 26 it's as if I knew you were
gonna say that with James White and Rex
Burkhead I almost do it
so just throwing out that nugget to back
up your instincts mr. lovak oh yeah I'm
gonna go pick up Rex Burkhead and
fantasy really quick like that guy
second greatest white running back in
the NFL alright let's go to Monday Night
Football and it is Vikings at Seahawks
and we are so far ahead of the game we
have no idea who's hurt we do know that
it's Kirk Cousins versus Russell Wilson
in primetime we do know that Kirk
Cousins was on vacation but the reason I
am bringing it up and I'm gonna take the
lead here is we know one piece of
information that is invaluable the lead
referee for Minnesota at Seattle is my
man Clete Blakeman why do I say he's my
man because he's ref ten games this year
at all ten of hit the under that's right
tendon oh you heard it here first last
week he was rough in Jets Raiders oh
baby what did he do and sand arnold
threw his first touchdown let's go to
new york it was a pick play pull back
and no touchdown took a little bit time
off it was great he is also in his last
15 12 and three to the underdog against
the spread clean
Blakeman there is nothing I like better
than yelling at Clete when there's an
illegal hands to the face Oh surprise
holding on a 50-yard touchdown cleat ooh
getting a little bit of momentum not
anymore
ten yards back second and 20 the line
for this game started at Seattle favored
by two and a half at home it is at three
and that line is at 49 I don't care what
information could give me eight nuggets
to the over Bettany under with CLE
Blakeman well this is certainly one
where you're gonna roll with that trend
yeah until it fall until the wheels fall
off have to because it's not just some
obscure you know well at night in night
games with you know tall grass and the
team's not gonna mow the grass too much
like this could happen is like a referee
who calls holding penalties on the
office of me because think about it
there's only a few penalties that that
referee is actually responsible for
calling and I mean frankly we talked
about integrity how could how can you
really be I don't want to ruin it for
you you know but how can you really be
undefeated every single one of your
games goes under the total and nobody's
looking into what this guy is up to I
mean I'm not gonna really get into it
for profit right and and you don't care
because you want to keep winning your
bets and I know that's fun red flag and
alert anybody important about this but
it seems it seems like this guy's
involved in something I don't know I
love it yeah so I'm just gonna make the
bet I don't know if I'm gonna do the
Minnesota wins in Seattle I just I don't
really want to be the guy that's betting
on Kirk Cousins unless you have any
information that really makes I mean
look man davon cook can run all over
that Seattle defense he really could
yeah they are lately they have Dallas
are Seattle's run defense how I do
see Xavier roads getting burned by DK
Metcalfe incessantly on Monday night
yeah it's gonna be interesting to see
how Seattle comes back in this game they
beaten who you know what this is Warren
this is Clete Blakeman plus by team on
the road it's two of the trends combined
showing offensive wheels could be
falling off with the Vikings and and and
their performance factor what was it was
it last year the year before that this
game this exact game happened in Seattle
on prime time and it was like 9 to 3 D
or some nonsense where they also had the
playoff game that was settled like 12 to
10 on the missed field goal by Blair
Walsh now that was in Minnesota right
but it's still those two teams it was it
was those two teams that one had like I
think that was like 10 degrees out
you know footballs were cold hard as a
rock it was difficult for anybody to
move the ball there but no these two
teams have they enter the game with a
mentality that this is going to be a
slugfest a battle a grind it out and
it's important to both of them to try to
get this win they're not gonna want to
make any mistakes
early they're gonna want to settle in
you know the one spark that really
Seattle had to get in order to win that
game against the Philadelphia Eagles
because if you look Seattle I think had
only three offensive plays inside the
Eagles 30-yard line they were really not
driving the ball down deep they had to
throw that flea-flicker and that got him
on the board early Rashad petty he
touched him and then and then a
breakaway run and a lot of these are
coming off of turnovers and mistakes
that the Eagles awesome making giving
Seattle a lot of opportunities so apart
from you know pulling out a random trick
play that offense did not do a lot in
Philadelphia last week they're out they
are at home this week but they're
playing another very good Minnesota
defense
man all right Clete Blackburn I'll be
rooting for him
Monday night Warren sharp Brian
Westbrook said that he does not eat mac
and cheese he thinks it is disgusting
your face is confused because it's
confusing because Brian Westbrook has
the worst taste in food I was curious if
there is a Thanksgiving side dish that
you do not partake in well let me ask
you this first because I'm I am curious
and I asked questions and I'm curious is
it a texture thing - hmmm texture he
does not like a soupy cheese he does not
like cheese except nachos which doesn't
make sense but it's Brian so it's okay
now literally is Paul is completely
doesn't make sense but um yeah I mean I
like mac and cheese of course is there a
side I don't like not really I'll steal
steer clear of like the green bean
casserole
green or casserole is like red velvet
cake to me where it looks and sounds
really good like when I see the green
beans the crust on top and I'm like oh
and then always I'm like it's still
green beans well it it does not sound
good to me because like green beans in
general I'm not a I'm not anti vegetable
first of all this podcast is not anti
vegetable or not I like eating healthy
and I like eating vegetables but if
you're gonna give me a smorgasbord of
all sorts of different options for one
meal
I'm gonna eat what I want to and I'm
going to not eat any vegetables if
that's why if if I want to fill a
limited space in my belly with the stuff
I find most tantalizing so like rule off
the let's break this down what
percentage of your stomach do you want
turkey on Thanksgiving um I would say I
don't know it's 20% solid 20% base you
know early down success rate you go
Turkey you come back stuffing is what
percentage seven eight or you attend I
would say ten Wow early down stuffing
rate very high we're at thirty percent
on just turkey and stuffing it's a good
base that's the twenty one personnel of
Thanksgiving well and and what I really
like the most that I only get once a
year my family has Croatian roots and
there is a dish called strip club which
is like this cut it up in squares and
it's been passed down in my family so my
mom makes it and it's like a gnocchi
type of situation it's it's like a
school it's a square and it's got like
egg and I mean dough that's like a
noodle doughy type thing but you pick it
up and eat it with your hands it's a
little bit thick and I'll wolf down like
five or six of those so you're probably
at a 20 percent Croatian delicacy there
yeah and then we also I mean what else
what else you want to throw out the
table I'll eat a little bit of sweet
potato casserole okay
I actually prefer that I'll eat like of
my potato ingestion yeah it'll be about
a 65 sweet potato 235 mash gravy I also
I'm the one who's taken over
responsibilities for the turkey and I
deep fried in peanut oil so that's why
that's why my turkeys hired like some
people probably don't watch the fry
temperature needed for peanut oil I do
it the easy way when that when that
orange light comes on it tells me and
dunk it in so I don't remember what it
is
I usually saw you as a thermometer guy I
really did
it's it's built into the unit so I don't
have to I don't have to think they make
it idiot proof so Wow and there is how
Warren sharp displaces percentage-wise
his Thanksgiving meal i I am like Jason
Garrett I don't know what happened but
I'll figure it out later
Warren you are the man keep kicking ass
glad you feel better any final messages
for the three three percent Emily do not
do not like it'll take time for grant
that's all I can say
beautiful Emily fun the four FS brought
to you by Warren sharp why are near the
man in Burr thanks for everything
homies out there have a great
Thanksgiving 33% enjoy it and we'll see
you next week enjoy the games it's gonna
be awesome
peace